[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello and welcome
to "The Developer Show."
This is your TL;DR. TensorFlow
makes it possible to add
machine learning to your
app without the PhD.
And you can now
learn all about it
with this new Udacity course.
This is one of the
most downloaded DJ apps
in the world.
After launching on
Android, the platform
became the largest contributor
of business growth,
with 50% of total
revenue and more than 70%
of new downloads coming
from their Android users.
Find out more with this
video linked below.
It's now gotten a
lot easier to share
an app's non-UI
code between iPhone,
iPod applications,
and Android and web
versions of the same app
using this new Google authored
open source compiler.
Check out the blog
post for more.
Our good friends
over at App Annie
have launched their
2015 retrospective,
looking at the key trends
from the last year,
including app monetization.
Learn the pros and cons of
different app monetization
models, how to
choose the one that's
right for you,
and considerations
for implementations with this
new guide from the AdMob team,
another in their no nonsense
series for developers.
We recently passed 1 million
students on the courses
we built in partnership
with Udacity.
It's a great time to
join them in learning
how to use this technology to
solve the world's most pressing
challenges.
You can now use promises with
the Firebase JavaScript SDK.
Check out the blog post
for more, also linked
in the comments below.
Now that's it for the TL;DR.
You may have noticed, however,
that we're out of
the studio again.
Today, we're down here at
the YouTube space in LA,
hanging out with
developer advocates
from around the world.
Now, you've been active with
the hashtag #AskDevShow.
So I'm going to spend the
day interrupting advocates
with your questions.
Let's get to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Asking me almost anything in
the comments or on social media,
and I'll get you your answer.
Teacher Aide Pro has a question
for Mr. Todd Kerpelman,
so I'm going to ambush
Todd in the studio
before he gets
started filming today.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Human torch was--
BOTH: Denied a bank loan.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Oh, that was good.
It really works with
that [INAUDIBLE].
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, hi, Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hi, Timothy.
I didn't notice you there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I have
a question for you.
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's hear it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Teacher
Aide Pro from the internets
asked this question about the
Classroom API and the Gmail
API.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: They like
to use it in their iOS apps
the way they're already
doing in their Android apps.
However, they found
that the Swift training
guide is a little out of date.
TODD KERPELMAN: What?
We have documentation
that's out of date?
All right, so Teacher
Aide Pro, there's
a couple things you
should be aware of.
First of all, all of our
iOS developer guides,
look for a radio
button at the top
that lets you select between
Objective-C and Swift.
Right now, it is
defaulted to Objective-C,
and it can be sometimes easy
to miss that radio button.
So click the Swift switch
and all of your code samples
and all of your
documentation will then
become Swift specific.
BOTH: Swift specific.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
that could be it.
That said, we did
talk to the team.
They have acknowledged
that there
may be some parts of
that documentation that
are out of date,
and they are working
on fixing it now or right
BOTH: Now.
TODD KERPELMAN: But
in the meantime,
they did point out that
all the code samples should
be accurate and up to date.
So if you notice a discrepancy
between the documentation
and the code samples, go
with what's in the code.
Use that [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Code samples.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
that should be good.
Well, thank you Teacher
Aide Pro for your question.
And if you have any other
follow-up questions, day
or night, on anything, no
matter how trivial, please just
call Timothy.
I'll give you his number.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN: Sure thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So I just spotted
Mr. Ian Lake getting
his portrait taken,
with I think we can interrupt.
Hi, Daniel.
DANIEL: Oh, hey, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello, Mr. Ian Lake.
IAN LAKE: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Do you mind
if I ask you a quick question?
IAN LAKE: Sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
you've asked "Dev Show"
with model-view-presenter
on Android,
where's the best place
to put the presenter?
Ian?
IAN LAKE: For our
presenter, it's
really important that it
survives those activity
rotations.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
IAN LAKE: Right?
But you don't want
it to live forever.
So we actually have
a class for this.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
IAN LAKE: It's called
AsyncTaskLoader.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: AsyncTaskLoader.
IAN LAKE: So it
does exactly that.
It will live just long
enough, whatever your activity
or fragment lifecycle is.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thanks Ian.
IAN LAKE: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So I spotted Rich.
He's sunbathing out here,
outside YouTube Space LA.
Great opportunity to ambush him
and get a little sun myself.
Shh.
[COUGHS]
RICH HYNDMAN: [LAUGHS]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How
you doing, Rich?
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So Super J
used the hashtag #AskDevShow
to ask you a question.
You ready for it?
RICH HYNDMAN: Go ahead.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Who owns whom?
Does Android own Google or
does Google own Android?
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
Absolutely the latter.
Android is Google's open
source mobile operating system.
We acquired Android
Inc in around 2005,
worked on it for
a couple of years,
and then launched the first
version of Android in 2007.
Some people thought a bit
of a risk at the time,
but it seems to have caught on.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
think it turned out OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
RICH HYNDMAN: All good?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, get
back to your hard work.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks very much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'll
catch you later.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's our show.
Remember to use the
hashtag #AskDevShow
to get your questions answered.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the channel for a new video
every week.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]